it's a beautiful day in Koreatown yes it
is yeah of course I love fried chicken
it's what we're good at we find good
fried chicken we've tasted all the fast
food fried chicken all the grocery store
fried chicken but you know we've never
done international fried chicken let's
start with one okay let's start with
Korean perfect we're in Koreatown it's a
chicken one chicken one duck rem-pod
chicky chicky one korean bought chicken
chicken chicken I should be I couldn't
do it I couldn't do it that's okay it's
okay so we're gonna goofily step into
frame that you stay right here
hello how are you doing yeah how are you
good so tell us about 77 Kentucky uh-huh
this is kind of that very traditional
Korean style fried chicken restaurant
I've never had Korean fried chicken yeah
never have I you're gonna love it
what is a wing bomb there was a wing
bomb because it sounds like you my
favorite things together yeah that's a
wing with that small like it looks like
a drumstick but the smaller oh it's just
a whole wing wing bomb wing bomb
- big bomb - big bones - big wings kind
of kind of uh-huh
Korean fried chicken how did it start so
I don't know exactly because like that
was before I you know existed chicken
wash rice at a strip beforehand
it's you actually knew that information
so I looked it up it's not in in 77 with
limbs chicken the first fried chicken
that was for another 80 to pellicano
chicken sausage took the fried chicken
and sauce and then toss it in 84 km/h
and chefs make a breeze go whoo now that
led to the rise of Korean chicken slots
now the interstates with us come out
chicken wash
yeah jig it washed Chris is gonna learn
how to make fried chicken today Korean
fried chicken right which I've never
made before but I'm very excited she can
watch I'm here with Jay and he's gonna
teach me how to make Korean fried
chicken
what is office research first like
colder than powder uh-huh what about
powder like is that the batteries out
that this is the secret stuff that uses
a lot of tongue it doesn't yet that's a
sick sick if you give me a hint what
that secret powder is cuz if you don't
tell me I'm gonna assume it's cocaine
ice water can make a more crispy oh the
ice water makes it work okay so this is
eggs milk and garlic and maybe some
others yes success
chupa chupa chupa no the chicken is
crazy colored the Mad Hatter to first
start with a little secret batter you
know it has garlic you know it had eggs
but Widow's doesn't have it got some leg
cause if you're running running running
running running to your mouth
running running running running running
to your mouth nothing else it straight
up Korea kicking up and just if you're
not you should watch
chicken watch I was look beautiful look
at them look a beautiful beautiful day
oh my god oh look at those little babies
America's mother fried chicken is like
with the dipping sauce right but we can
mix with ourselves that we have a lot of
flavor like regular fried and then
Chinese style barbecue style and a
colleague and his story sauce and then
we're gonna mix it yes you're such a man
so you can watch do you have something
that's like crazy crazy crazy spicy yeah
you don't have it too spicy yeah I can
do that it'll make me cry but I'll try
it
it'll make I will cry I won't weep in
your store openly it's really gonna hurt
me I have it very sensitive time yeah I
will oh [ __ ]
check it watch just look at this
presentation there's a bunch of
different fried chicken and fries and a
huge silver boat we're gonna go plain
garlic Chinese chicken and crazy spicy
which is called angel whoa my god
then toll - oh dang Cho look at this
your tongue is like this high bang yep
lot I gotta use my local town
fingers okay well it's not smell oh good
well scratch this skin is so crispy
what's that different flavor like it's
different than ordinary fried chicken
something in there
don't worry not cocaine that's not okay
but it's still so boy what could it be
all right let's go garlic right mm-hmm I
got a little bond no cuz it's just arm
one good bond
that's good but I'm gonna be honest I
kind of like the plain one even better
it's got a really good sweetness to
Darla Kunis but yeah this just the just
the straight-up right chicken it's okay
yeah
step it up what is the Kung Pao is the
Congress on when I grilled up but you
have this for Chinese chicken right
Chinese a factory of the tiny chicken
I'm so impressed with again how moist
this is this was cooked twice for me the
grilled twice doesn't justify the
texture as much yeah it's softer because
it's got sauce cooked into it right that
was the most moist of all of them okay
all right now we're gonna try the spicy
one with dad imagine is gonna be so
spicy that we're gonna be able wrong
keith has very sensitive taste buds
speaking of taste does
so let's get the key crime meter up on
the screen
I see no Machpelah I'm gonna have to you
know it smells spicy yeah it's also
sticky
[Music]
Oh oh wow that's high it's like it's in
it's on your tongue
oh really even harder for chem like it
is like a hot tea no feel where you want
to keep going one time when I was a
little kid I ate a ghost pepper in a
Chinese restaurant why would you do that
Chinatown because I don't know it's got
to be cool in front of my cousin's and I
want to vomiting and like the rest of
the day it also is fine while you're
eating it and two minutes later it's
like your head is on fire
go get some more napkins blow my nose oh
dear God
Oh chicken watch oh look at this pink
crime here
you okay my tongue is sore she can watch
right that's good so let's answer the
question
yeah do you think this is the best fried
chicken in the world I you know are we
even qualified to figure out the best
fried chicken in the world is chicken
watch so we got all this chicken and
there's some nice fellas over here we're
gonna offer them some chicken
you guys are you want some fried chicken
with us in exchange for all this chicken
if you guys could just do some dope
skateboarding tricks with us in the
background WW lid I loved the plane the
most some of the Krispies fried chicken
I've ever had
[Music]
the saucing was good too and I would go
with the spicy one is my second choice I
got I got crazy sauce turn take it away
I think the presentation beats any
presentation I've ever had is awesome
yeah for any fried chicken really in
this place they also do the 1977 style
just fried chicken they also do whole
fried chickens here I can't figure out
how I feel about like the homage to
Kentucky you know which ones you don't
got a copy Kentucky Korea be yourself I
think they were inspired by the colonel
they've left us with a kernel of what
they started with
Wow oh wow
I think this could be the best fried
chicken in the world where else should
we try what part of the world do you
think has the best fried chicken let us
know in the comments we'll try to hit
that place next on chicken watch TV
watch chicken wash chicken watch
oh yeah oh yeah I got fell down
immediately
that's alright cuz you okay he's great
everything's good on chicken watch baby
chicken